talk to your doctor you know what you
know who yes and you know who you should
which doctor I don't think you should
talk to is Doctor
cheese you know we got this story
from we are sorry if you got his numbers
we got the story we got the story from
Reuters U.S plans to give extra covid-19
shots to at-risk Americans fouchy says
that is the third shot for people who
are in at-risk groups if you are
immunocompromised people like cancer
survivors those who are HIV positive
they are saying that they are trying to
rush through approval for your third
shot now over in Israel
we have this from Voice of America after
another covet Spike Israel launches
third vaccine dose they say Israel has
become the first country to distribute a
third dose of the coveted vaccine
offering the extra jab to anyone over
60. Israeli Health experts say the
effectiveness of the current vaccine
declines with time and the third shot
will serve as a booster the move comes
as virus rights in Israel are on the
increase now
this is crazy viral video which they say
is a report from Israel's Channel 13
where they say in this Twitter and this
Twitter which I this tweet which I'm
I've not confirmed a translation that
the hospitalization rates are
overwhelmingly those who have been
vaccinated in Israel is saying we are
not finding this to be effective now I
don't know if that's true yeah well and
also we have to know what percentage the
population is vaccinated to because if
an overwhelming majority of the
population is vaccinated and
overwhelming pup you know majority are
in the hospital it's proportional then
we could say well it doesn't seem to be
working in this instance but if a
majority are in the hospitals whereas an
overwhelming majority is vaccinated then
it seems it would be working to some
extent or you could make that argument
so we don't really know they say an
Israeli study showed effectiveness of
the covid vaccine decline from 95 to 80
oh wow or even less against the Delta
variant neither the U.S nor the EU has
yet recommended a third shot but most
Israeli doctors say they do not believe
it will do any harm now we have we had a
story we pulled up the other day from
timcast.com that shows I think it was
like Pfizer and ashrazeneca to be like
92 and 96 percent effective against the
Delta variant so all I can do is tell
you this
talk to your doctor because I don't you
know I I know for for those on the live
show like right now it's more repetitive
but in the segments like yeah you know
so we have to say it
um because I don't know what this means
I really really don't Israel is making a
lot of claims that a lot of people in
the U.S are shocked to hear very
interesting and and don't know if they
want to believe to be completely honest
that that you know what Israel is saying
about the effectiveness so here's why I
bring this up
um not not only is that happening but
the World Health Organization is calling
for a temporary moratorium on vaccine
booster shots because they want to
prioritize global distribution of the
vaccine to poorer Nations okay so I have
no idea
um yeah I can tell you this it sounds
like humans run around like these
organizations are like chickens with
their head cut off is that true though
do you cut a chicken sound if it runs
around yes I'm not sure I mean you're
the one with chickens Tim I'm not I'm
not cutting their heads off you know he
just doesn't want to admit it on stream
because you know Petey's going to get it
that's true uh my family he'll get
canceled really yeah yeah it's true
though don't get canceled my family
raised chickens and yes this is the
thing that
wow I never questioned that no of course
not
yeah I'm curious I am curious what
percentage of the population in Israel
is vaccinated what percentage of new
cases did they set were say were
vaccinated people well that's there's a
tweet and I don't speak Hebrew so I
can't really confirm that anyway you
know but people are claiming that
there's a doctor who says it's like the
overwhelming majority of the coveted
patients in the hospitals have been
vaccinated that is fascinating yeah but
again I can't confirm any of that stuff
all I know is that uh fauci is rushing
out a third shot here in America for
people who are you know compromised the
the eviction uh moratorium was illegally
a new one was illegally put in place and
the unemployment checks are going out so
it smells like uh lockdown I guess you
know they say if it walks like a
lockdown you know acts like a lockdown
and sounds like a lockdown then it's
probably a lockdown right yeah exactly
I'm hearing from a Reuters their numbers
say that the number of doses in Israel
administered has been 11 million and so
if that's at two doses per person that's
63.2 percent of the country being
vaccinated it's a little bit higher than
the US I think I think the US's rate was
uh like what 49 or something like that
the United States is right of
vaccinations well I have some data here
saying that they asked um
adults and they found that seven in ten
adults said they have already gotten it
or are getting it as soon as possible so
something like 67 have already gotten it
and uh three more percent say they're
going to get it as soon as possible
Australia's like 18 why is they've
gotten vaccinated yeah I think they just
don't trust their government I guess it
could also Australian is not is I I
think Australia's population is much
more spread out um
I think maybe if if your government is
not treating you very well then you're
probably not going to be too happy okay
no it's it's uh it's higher right now
okay oh no no yeah fully vaccinated 16
whoa wow that's low
wow well at least one dose is 34.2
percent oh
wow that's so bad where in Australia so
that's of the population yeah of the
population 16.3 are fully vaccinated wow
that's that's really really low it's
abysmal wow yeah yeah why is that that's
like the most heavily cracked down
country on Earth that's probably why it
could definitely crack down upon it I
also think it's the population density
uh it is really uh it's it's something
partially populated sparsely populated
so the numbers I have here are three
people per squared kilometer in the
United States the average population
density is 94 people
um yeah but they've got cities dude no
I'm not saying they don't but I don't I
think that more of their population
lives in rural areas
it's tough to say based on average
numbers but
I think their population is more spread
out than ours is their population is
what like 25 million or something it's
not Betty yeah so we have 10 times yeah
so I they have big cities you know that
I and they're and they've got military
deployed to enforce the lockdown no I'm
not saying they don't have big cities
but I'm saying overall they're less
densely populated which means there are
more people who live further away from
other people
you don't think Australia's average
population is less dense than I'm saying
Australia like two to one yeah Australia
is as big as the U.S with a tenth of the
population so it's not that they're
living
it's that there's a big open Outback
desert nothing in the middle of the
continent okay what was U.S population
that's only 20 how many people 370
million no density density oh the
population density
um 94 people per square in Australia was
like nine oh actually Australia
Australia so so the United States is but
the United States is information I just
gave you is Miles so if you look in
kilometers it's 36 people per kilometer
squared words right so three people ten
times the population yeah I know that
makes sense very similar why is the
vaccine rate in Australia 16 did you
pull the vaccination rate for the U.S
actually well I think I had some numbers
pulled up from earlier and it said again
about 70 percent of people have already
gotten it or getting it as soon as
possible wow wow no no no no no no no
it's fifth it's
50.4 of the of people in the United
States are fully vaccinated
165 million people go at least one dose
is 58.7 percent Australia
16.3 I think when you crack down when
you start arresting people for not
wearing masks and you deploy military
people are not going to try yeah it
would be less likely I'm also curious
what Australia is like culturally too I
I wonder if they're as divided as the
United States is or if there's a more
unified front in terms of the skepticism
that they have towards government
mandates not sure well authoritarianism
this is why it doesn't work because you
lose you you lose the faith and the
confidence of the people and so we were
having this conversation I think it was
um I don't know if it was with watching
Charlie in the bonus segment or
something about like uh authoritarianism
is effective in that you can mandate
things really really quickly and that's
technically true the problem is it
derails itself it falls apart because if
you don't have confidence of the people
the system can't be supported the the
government is an imaginary construct of
people's confidence like why is a dollar
valuable if you showed a dollar to you
know an alien they'd be like it's I
don't need this what am I gonna do with
it now gold they might understand like
ah you know a conductor I can do
something with this money they're going
to be like sure I don't know what you
you like this they might think it's a
really cool picture yeah like oh it's a
picture and they put on the wall there's
different kinds of it it's not
functional of authoritarianism too
there's the authority of one man which
is like totalitarian you know
dictatorship and then there's the
authority of the of a constitution like
a written document and that's also a
form of authoritarianism no it isn't
it's really not but it is a form of
Authority so they they basically not all
authorities authoritarians right the
founding fathers are generally used as a
yeah I would like to explain to you what
Authority is go for it when a police
officer in New York says you can't stand
there that's a frozen Zone which is what
they do that is not that is
authoritarianism that is them just
arbitrarily deciding I can do this you
want to know what real Authority is
Sheamus drops to the ground ah and
there's blood spring everywhere and a
doctor looks you in the eye and says put
your put put your hands on his neck
right now what would you say
absolutely just do it exactly if you
were out in the street and you saw
somebody hurt and there was a guy he's
like I'm a doctor you come here now put
your hands here you would not think
twice exactly because you know that's
what real Authority is but if there was
some crackpot guy on a on a in a
rickshaw and he was had people pulling
him and he was like you there you know
come here and kneel so I can walk on
your back because I and leave my Richard
you'd be like get out of here that's
insane and then if he threatened you
with a weapon to make you do it
authoritarian
I think that the reason I brought up the
founding fathers again is because they
established like a I don't know two
decades of massive authoritarianism in
order to install a constitution that
they could step back from and release
their Authority what do you mean by that
like they were like George Washington an
ultimate authority over the land they
would have made him King he could have
become a monarch
and and big that doesn't mean
authoritarianism though but that they
they functioned authoritarian
authoritatively to to build the
Constitution to seize the the million
Washington was given his troops
vaccinated against their will you know
like pure on martial law authoritarian
Crackdown to win the Revolutionary War
that's war and then instead of one guy
maintaining authoritarianism being like
and now this is legal but now it's not
and now that's the new thing we just
built a set of laws that could take over
for us the fact that they gave up power
and enacted the Constitution shows it
was never authoritarian it was just it
was just you can use authoritarianism
for good they seem to have
I I but I don't think it was
authoritarianism I don't think that that
falls in in line with it it was it was
hey we want freedom oh no they're
attacking us quick everyone come
together here's what we have to do to
survive like if the house started
burning down and I grabbed you and
dragged you out of the house is that
authoritarianism technically no come on
no I mean if if it hit the fan and you
had to like take control of everything
passed out from smoke inhalation but he
hasn't chosen to leave so I'm not an
authoritarian I'm leaving him in the
building
it's freedom to sleep during the fire I
mean it's interesting so so the word
authority and the word author come from
the same place which is Creator someone
creates something they have authority
over it or if they have given you
they've delegated The Authority uh over
their creation to another person than
that person has authority over it um and
of course it comes ultimately from God
creating the universe delegating
authority to specific Civil Authorities
but a belief in Authority is not the
same as a belief that
unbridled authoritarianism is acceptable
yeah do you when you think of unbridled
authoritarianism do you think of it as
like dictatorial yeah so I would say
usurpation anytime an authority
structure absorbs the role of a smaller
more vulnerable Authority structure when
it doesn't have to do so I would call
that authoritarianism so basically
anytime subsidiarity is violated so I
believe that there are all sorts of
authority structure Authority structures
across Humanity so you have the the
family structure which is an authority
structure you have the father at the
head of the household and then you also
have local governments state governments
a national government
and if one higher authority
quote-unquote higher authority in that
hierarchy comes down and takes a role
which is proper to one of the lower
authorities so for example if the state
starts to interfere with family life in
ways that are proper to a father I
believe that's authoritarianism because
somebody is taking the rightful
Authority away from one and giving
Authority which is not due to another to
them what's interesting I think when
they have to only if if they don't have
to and you got to Define what does that
mean if someone feels like they have to
step in and take the authority like what
I can exploit a virus make someone think
I can explain to authoritarianism and
libertarianism somewhat uh with a great
way um so the Democrats right now
believe the economy is going good why
because the authority told them and they
have strict adherence to the authority
which says this is what you must do they
say okay the economy is good yes sir
Trump supporters were told by Trump to
get the vaccine and they said no
authoritarian
yeah we live in the kind of
self-authored society the Constitution
is sort of supposedly self-authored by
the by us we the people
we are a freedom-loving people but we
are losing them what interests me is
that they they they seized authoritarian
dictatorship for a short period of time
in order to create a self-authored
society or also it's a sweet thing and
plus people could have just fled I guess
there have been cowards and I don't know
England yeah it was it was it was a lot
harder back then I suppose but they were
loyalists there were people who said no
to the revolution
that made me think of if we hadn't had
was it South Carolina the slave states
if they hadn't joined us Not only would
they just not have been in their
fighting they would have been all
loyalist you know what really funny
though is that they would have had to
abolish slavery sooner if they were men
with the crown but this is really
interesting actually in that regard
because I talked about this because a
lot of people have said If America never
declared independence slavery would have
ended 20 years earlier and I'm like I'm
not sure that's true that's true at all
imagine the crown of Britain said we're
mandating in 1833 the end of slavery the
southern states would have declared
independence but the whole British
ending slavery things kind of a fallacy
because they did what was called
enclosure I was just watching if they're
in Kings in General's YouTube channel
about this yesterday enclosures
basically where the Lords of the land
seized the land from every all the
civilians 90
99.98 of of British land is owned by
like point zero one percent of the
population since like the 1600s since
they started enclosure well and also if
the United States was still under
British rule the economic and political
incentives would be entirely different
from the crown from what they were when
England wasn't overseeing the United
States and decided to end slavery so I
don't think you could say that if we
stayed with the crowd and slavery would
have ended soon I don't think you could
possibly know that but they might have
let it roll in in the Americas yeah
because it was making them so much money
yeah they would just colonize or because
or because they they feared some kind of
Revolt right because the southern states
seceded and revolted
um so I have no reason to believe that
the British government wouldn't have the
foresight to say oh that will probably
happen or could happen I think so to me
it's it's not something you could
possibly I love my English homeless man
with the British government terrifies me
a monarchy in today's age
our government scares me a lot more but
I mean you see Britain like the the the
the Commonwealth is struggling Canada
and Australia are are and New Zealand
are getting messed up right now by
Authority and then they got the god king
at the top like
it's crazy yeah but it's not like the
crown actually does anything yeah it's a
ceremony it's all behind they own land
is what they do yeah they basically
control everything through ownership we
got we have that in the United States
too bro
Trinity Church Trinity uh in like New
York one of the largest landowners no I
didn't know that church Bureau of Land
Management the Vatican in China yeah
they have a lot of land
yeah that's how you do it I guess you
own the land like uh like Ray Crock you
know like we're not doing anything we
just own the land yeah own the land
under the McDonald's that's an active
process to own land yeah yeah
yeah will we uh
we yeah I wonder what the future holds
for us yeah I don't know maybe no we're
700 and like real healthy and stuff live
till 700 and be real healthy well once
you get the 5 000th jab you might make
it yeah you're gonna make it five
thousand well look to be fair they've
been saying since the beginning they
were expecting to be like a yearly thing
yeah like a flu shot yeah exactly I mean
they've said that they think this is
going to be like a seasonal flu the
issue is they didn't force me to get the
flu shot you know if you walk into
Walgreens and they're like would you
like to and it's like you know maybe
yeah I guess yeah yeah I went to the
doctor once I told the story like you
know he gave me like four or five shots
or whatever yeah yeah all at once
there's an entirely different culture
around it people don't shame you for not
getting the flu yeah I know people that
would get the flu shot and then get the
flu because they their immune systems
would be so so beat up by the shot that
then they wouldn't be eating healthy and
then they'd end up getting sick anyway
so what's the point the problem with the
flu shot is that we develop it in
conjunction with Australia because their
flu season is ahead of ours sometimes
they have a different strain of the flu
than we have so by the time the flu shot
comes here and we're using it we're like
oh this will work for our strain right
sometimes sometimes not like there was
one year I remember at the hospital they
gave us all the shots great it was
wonderful tons of people still got the
flu it was something like 30 effective
because the Australian strain just
wasn't very much like the American
strain I remember reading a while ago
this was before covid this is before
anyone was really talking about this
before there was any you know seeming
controversy over vaccines as far as I
could tell but I remember reading that
flu vaccines were becoming less
effective on a yearly basis and it was a
serious problem that had to be dealt
with I haven't heard anything I mean I
think the the the the discourse
surrounding vaccines has clearly moved
on to other issues if that is the case
but it's becoming the challenge is I
think one of the reasons you see these
stories where people think the vaccine
is more dangerous is because of the
authoritarianism of of the media and the
left the overstate the cathedral
whatever you want to call it one of the
people who always lie to you tell you
something's good you're not going to
believe them and they've discredited
themselves over the past few years like
russiagate is is you know you know what
for everybody's listening if you ever
get you ever get somebody who's like you
know oh you you believe that stuff be
like Russia yeah sorry like you lost all
credibility with the New York Times The
Washington Post and and CNN and all
these MSNBC were screaming Russia for
years and it was all bunk you lost me
dude sorry and also like there is
precedent for them lying and moving the
goal post about this as well this very
situation two weeks to slow the spread
oh the idea is we just want people
locked down so that the hospitals don't
get overwhelmed with new patients
yeah everyone forgot about that it was
two weeks to slow the spread and the
whole point was 15 15 days 15 days I'm
sorry a day over two weeks to slow the
spread because we didn't want hospitals
to get overwhelmed and what happened
they didn't get overwhelmed exactly but
did we stop at two weeks so we've
already been lied to about this and the
narrative has changed even if you don't
want to say we were lied to the
narrative clearly changed the goal post
has moved so people have no reason to
believe it's not going to move if they
go and get the vaccine or do whatever
else they're being told yeah that these
people would scold you and talk down to
you for not taking their word for it
after they've repeatedly misrepresented
what the future would be if we were to
take their word for it is ridiculous the
lack of self-awareness is astounding
even for them this is why I always say
talk to yourself
I say because because listen [ __ ] your
droplets I don't care the politics there
are people who make money off of shock
content be it somebody who is like in a
hospital about going I wish I got the
vaccine or somebody being like my legs
don't work it's like the people are
going to find the stories that get the
clicks and that's why you need to find
someone you trust who's done the
research and there are people who tell
me that they don't trust their doctors
I'm like then you need a good doctor
dude lots of doctors it's okay to travel
from Doctor to doctor they call them
second opinion get a second opinion
exactly it's the age of like multiple
opinions get lots and lots of doctors
opinions well just just make sure that
you trust they've done their research
that they're qualified because it's
insane to me that anyone would would
think that I'm implying you go to a
quack doctor in an alley like no I'm
saying you go someone and you ask some
questions say here's what I saw what do
you think and here's what I said earlier
like if you see a story show them yeah
see see what they think yeah exactly
exactly exactly because if there's
nothing to it then your doctor should
generally be able to explain to you well
sometimes times these things happen or
whatever it is but but the statistics
I've seen in my research shows that it
is safe if it is right so let me let me
let me let me add um the doctor I had in
my neighborhood we knew our doctor yes
that's huge I was about to bring that up
actually it's not just talking to your
doctor and it's not just talking to a
doctor who you've known or not a fact
because because maybe you don't have a
doctor who you go to primarily it is
really helpful to just have friends who
are doctors or like a life who's a
doctor folks oh yeah but if you have
friends who are doctors who you
genuinely trust who you aren't
necessarily seeing that you're gonna
still talk about these issues about this
stuff thanks for checking out this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast if you want
to see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com
timcastirl Monday through Friday at 8 pm
where you can leave comments and Super
Chat and we actually will read your
comments on the show don't forget to
like share subscribe and if you want
exclusive members only content segments
you can't get anywhere else go to Tim
us.com become a member and we even have
full bonus episodes thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time